everyone Peter and Justin here for a
breaking news update Tuesday morning
brought one big surprise irrational
games is shutting down yeah not a very
happy way to start our Tuesday morning
Ken Levine
wrote in a blog post on the irrational
games website that he's not necessarily
shutting down the entire studio but he
he wants to kind of go back to his roots
he wants to go back and start making
games that he started when he was a tree
irrational and those are smaller teams
more a more in depth experience I mean
he is a very creative individual he's
the guy who wrote BioShock Infinite he
recently wrote the screenplay to Logan's
Run but he's not the kind of guy that I
think of as a CEO as the head of a
company and that's been his role for the
past couple years now right so it seems
like you know if this is what he wants
to do right after BioShock Infinite it
might be the right time and part of it
is also probably a little bit of fatigue
I mean he he is a creative guy he
probably wants to work on different
projects and when you're kind of
pigeon-holed at irrational games the
maker of Bioshock
I'm sure he's told a lot that the next
thing he needs to make is another
Bioshock and probably his way of
stepping away from that completely of
getting away from having to make another
Bioshock is just to completely start
over basically all right Justin so what
does this actually mean for the future
of the Bioshock series if Ken Levine and
irrational games aren't going to be
involved so ken Levine is probably not
going to be involved in Bioshock going
forward but 2k still has control of it
he's basically given complete control
over to 2k and 2k had it before they did
Bioshock 2 without irrational games and
it just it seems like that's probably
gonna be more of what's gonna happen
going forward so we're probably gonna
see more Bioshock but less BioShock
Infinite in the original Bioshock and
more like Bioshock 2 which wasn't a
flood experience but very very different
from those other ones the guys who are
working at the studio now are gonna be
given the next few days the next few
weeks to try and find new jobs to line
up interviews with publishers their
stuff get the hell out yeah hey you know
our thoughts go out to those affected
it's definitely a sad time whenever
anyone loses their job especially when a
really well-loved studio is just it's
kind of out of the blue
stops to exist yeah it's very strange it
had a lot of build-up over the past few
years and here we are now we'll be
following up with the guys at irrational
at 2k and trying to talk to Ken Levine
himself to bigger
what his thoughts are and what he has
planned next so stay tuned to game
spotto to read more about that as this
story develops